attention vous entrez dans un monde sans
mensonge
[Musique]
je finis consoler prince de sa rage de
retrouver cinéma pas mais on peut se
passe tous les soirs en son nom
franchement la flemme temps je vais pas
passer toute la soirée est écoutée chez
rire monsieur s'il vous plaît s'il vous
plaît pas tant parce qu'on fait si
longtemps le con il entend mais j'aime
bien qu'on va te plusieurs fois ça fait
genre s'occuper plein de trucs à faire
alors je vous sers quoi il va je prenais
qui affiche des cas alors le point de
casser le cul je vais faire comme
d'habitude directement le cap et allez
c'est parti pour le cap est bon oui il
faut qu'on trouve une meuf est vite mais
ça sert à rien je suis encore amoureux
d'elle
je veux dire tu pourrais marc déry un
axe ça m'intéresserait croix tiens
regarde lunettes n'attaquait lunettes la
lune est bon voire secret ouais quitte à
faire ça j'aurais préféré rihanna quand
même un question je suis obligé de te
parler parce que ma copine tu interpellé
mais bon je t'explique
j'aime me suis remarié et déjà ça donne
pas du tout envie et je sais qu'en plus
j'ai encore un peu amoureux d'elle donc
tu fais quoi ce soit assez sage et déjà
un plan cul ma fille moi ton numéro 6 1
soir chaubouret c'est possible que je
t'appelle et tu verras c'est un grand
romantique un son film préféré ses coups
de feu en exil donc pas du tout non
c'est love actually et je m'attache très
vite au jeu ça changera des mecs qui
s'attachent pas un bon by ap les
casernes qu'elle soit brune à ça ça va
être long je suis bretonne capital si
les pee wee mon coeur non c'est bon j'ai
fini ma mission humanitaire
j'arrive je peux venus en finale vous
ayez atteint petit demandent s'ils
peuvent venir compliquer ok bisous à
tout meilleurs depuis deux places banon
elle voulait pas que tu viennes non plus
d'ailleurs
je filme
[Musique]